Now that we have this book object and we've tested it, let's put it to use.
You're going to write a program that takes a user input word, and tells how
many times it occurs. Your code will be able to do this. When you're done with
this you'll be able to run look up any word. It'll ask you to type a word and
it'll look it up. So, I'll type Hatter and press Enter. And it tells me Hatter
occurs 55 times. I'm going to give you some pointers. You'll want to make a new
book, like we do in BookTester. You'll also need to use a scanner, don't forget
the import. Also, you saw how to read and enter a double, but you didn't see
how to read a string with the scanner. You'll need to look at the scanner
documentation. Scanner has a lot of methods, you'll want to use one of the ones
that starts with next and returns a string. If picking the right scanner method
makes your head hurt, click the link that says hints. I'll go over this part in
detail in the answer video.